ça c'est bizarre je sais pas si c'est
normal je sais pas s'ils doivent
inquiéter
[Musique]
c'est un exercice que je n'aime pas
faire je suis pas là pour casser les
marques en règle générale quand on
propose de tester des produits et que
ses pas il ya un truc qui va pas avec
eux qui se passe pas bien
je refuse je teste pas c'est pour ça
qu'en règle générale hyper enthousiaste
est toujours assez heureux et je vais
souvent les éloges des produits parce
que je choisis des smartphones ou des
produits rhin le général que j'aime là
on m'a proposé de tester un smartphone
qui vient de chine
ce qui me pose absolument aucun problème
un smartphone extrêmement résistant
c'est un smartphone tout terrain un
smartphone fait pour l'extérieur qu'on
peut emmener qui absolument résistant à
l'eau ip68 qui peut prendre des chocs
qui ne bouge pas et c'est surtout le
smartphone le moins cher dans sa
catégorie à 100 euros voire moins de 100
euros en fonction des offres
promotionnelles
du coup je me suis dit bon il faut le
tester selon les promesses de la marque
donc quand l'adn d'un smartphone c'est
sa robustesse son étanchéité qui est
fait pour aller en extérieur et qui ne
craint absolument rien qu'est ce que je
fais je le prends je me mets dans l'eau
je le coût de tous les côtés et je vois
ce que ça donne sauf que là après on
fait tremper pendant une demi heure
j'ai un bug le mieux c'est je vous
laisse regarder par vous même je vous
ramène au début du test
je pars d'une façon très neutre et naïve
et puis à la fin mais je vous dirai ce
que je fais de ce smartphone
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un smartphone
qui est pas particulièrement cher ça
change c'est plutôt pas mal
l'idée de smartphones c'est d'avoir un
produit qui est hyper résistant un
produit qui est vraiment fait pour aller
partout qui peut tomber qui se cassera
pas un espèce de produits un peu tout
terrain certifié pour la poussière
certifié pour l'oph a vraiment hyper
hyper hyper résistante et qui coûte
vraiment mais vraiment pas cher ce
smartphone il est par là on sait pas du
tout ce que vous avez devant on va
bondir par derrière
on la tra il est là il est beau il est
chaussé le pop tels c'est le p 8
et on n'a pas tout de suite au moins
vous soyez coutumier des smartphones
chinois je ne pense pas que vous
connaissiez ce smartphone pop tels p8
cherche il n'y a pas très longtemps et
l'idée c'est avec ninon de vous
présenter ce smartphone si vous voulez
quelque chose d' extrêmement résistant
mais vraiment dans des conditions
costaude
bon on va pas comparer à des marques
comme cros cole qui sont effectivement
aussi du tout terrain comme caterpillar
cas aussi du tout terrain et beaucoup
d'outils mais on a un peu l'adn c'est à
dire qu'on aime l'idée en tout cas c'est
d'abord un produit aussi résistant qu'un
gros score lourd caterpillar
je sais pas si c'est le cas à des prix
vraiment hyper bas en termes de
spécifications techniques on a et u qui
sont un peu cheap forcément en laissant
d'entrée de gamme mais partir je peux
franchement le faire donc
saint-hippolyte et est aujourd'hui on va
donc voir si ce pop tels p8 qu'un ses
promesses oui ou non cela ne soit pas
forcément chercher d'avoir un truc qui
est tout de suite hyper cali en terme de
packaging
forcément il ya coûter un peu de suppose
un peu cartons parce que on va gagner en
termes de coûts lorsqu'on est parce qu
on a connu mieux en terme de packaging a
même tendance un petit peu à tomber tous
les côtés bon on va essayer de démêler
un peu tout ça le smartphone on le
regarde dans quelques instants on est
ici une protection d'écran ça c'est
costaud très costaud de la recharge en
micro usb aussi pour des questions de
coût ça c'est des petites serviettes
pour nettoyer l'écran quand il est
mouillé quand il est sec et loire ouais
ouais bon je lui ouvre une fois je vois
deux fois ok ça marche ici on a quoi
c'est le bloc de charge qui est jusque
là ok
voilà petit poste n'a pas trop trop lui
en demander qu'est ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur ensuite de la documentation
qui dit de démarrage rapide ici la
garantie et puis je crois qu'on a fait
un petit peu le tour de la question
le smartphone maintenant ah oui comme
tous les smartphones de cette gamme très
résistants ils sont hyper récifs très
très très très massif très très très
très épais le poids ses 231 g bon c'est
ce qu'on va chercher là dessus on
cherche de la robustesse on peut pas
avoir de robustesse avec la smart phones
qui n'est pas épais qui n'est pas massif
ça ne marche pas voilà un peu pour la
bête alors on n'a pas trop tardé
on enlève ça tout de suite on enlève ça
tout de suite
dites moi comment vous le trouvez en
commentaire si vous avez cette
l'hippologie de produits attention on va
pas comparer avec un iphone avec un
produit samsung wave boat show c'est pas
du tout ce pas du tout du tout l'adn de
ce produit est l'adn de ce produit c'est
d'avoir quelque chose de commentcamarche
un truc quelque chose d extrêmement
résistant à ça c'est votre tiroir de
cartes sim et qui s'enlève avec l'ongle
ah ouais ça c'est assez assez ouf
bon on a deux cartes sim voir l'allemand
de la nano sim et de la micro sim là
dessus ici on a quoi bouton de volume
bouton pour l'allumer pour autant le
bouton je ne sais pas ce que c'est eh
ben on va l'allumer revoir que sadique
pop tels qu'android est parce qu il
tombe sur un android 8.1 oreo sur le
pays 8 la qualité est pas exceptionnel
l'accueil que l'écran est pas terrible
le tactile est pas non plus
extraordinaire
il fait le job on est sur un smartphone
à 100 euros il fait le job pas trop lui
en demander
on lui demande d'avancer de reculer de
bouger il le fait bon l'écran est pas
hyper hyper lumineux pas trop trop lui
en demander
après soyez pas trop gourmand en voulant
regarder des vidéos sur youtube c'est
pas un smartphone qui est fait pour ça
il a un écran de 5 pouces avec une
résolution de 960 par 480 pixels 215
pixels par pouce c'est pas énorme
daly psc du lcd pour l'utiliser dans des
conditions extérieures c'est vraiment
besoin d'un deuxième smartphone pour moi
là dessus il fera le job à côté de ce
niveau
buisson le fonds vient de derrière si
vous avez vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de fonds il ya un
volume sonore complètement dingue alors
après c'est à ces médiums mais par
contre il ya vraiment beaucoup de volume
là dessus après si vous voulez brancher
un casque vous avez si une petite prise
jack up quand vous l'utilisez plus vous
repoussez ça se ferment bien et de
l'autre côté ici faut tirer un peu
forcément ses protégés vous avez ici
votre port micro usb pour recharger
votre smartphone up court terme et pour
appuyer on n'en parle plus après ce cas
c'est sympa c'est que lorsque vous
voulez faire des photos vous avez un
bouton qui est dédié ici vous mettez là
hop vous appuyer ça vous fait une petite
photo c'est plutôt sympa alors c'est
pareil en termes de photos voyez la
qualité est pas extraordinaire j'ai fais
vraiment un truc à l'arraché il faut
savoir qu'elle a rien ici vous avez un
capteur de 8 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.2 pas trop leur demande
en termes de luminosité
c'est très bien pour les photos plein
jour en extérieur et l avant vous avez
ici une caméra de 5 mégapixels et j'ai
pas d'info sur l'ouverture
bon les specs sont pas dingue là dessus
bien écoutez c'est normal on est sur un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme
on va tester la robustesse dans quelques
secondes donc là comme ça on en saura
davantage mais par contre tout ce qui
est écrans caméras mais une puissance
sauf faut pas trop lui en demander
parce qu'il tourne soudain médiathèque
6739 quatre coeurs cadencés jusqu'à 1,8
gigahertz de giga de ram 16 go de
stockage
par contre le capteur d'empreintes
digitales à l'arrière marche plutôt pas
mal
il ya du nfc la puissance des haut
parleurs vous allez jusqu'à 106 décibels
donc lorsque vous serez à l'extérieur
lassus croyez moi vous avez du son on va
maintenant regarder si ce téléphone est
vraiment solide
oui ou non pour ça on a une petite
batterie de tests sympathique et le
faire subir premier test l'eau il doit
pouvoir tenir une demi heure là dedans
sans problème
on va faire une demi-heure qu'il est
dans l'eau attention plus que quelques
secondes à venir vont le suspense lie
complètement insoutenable attention bon
allez gnagnagna gna gna gna gna aller ça
y est on y est allés bim 30 minutes
voyons voir maintenant je suppose que ça
va le faire
il est toujours par contre ici ça
m'allume un peu la prise jack
on allume le casque sais pas pourquoi il
est là il est beau il est encore en vie
il marche il s'allume l'écran marche bon
dans l'eau l'écran marchait pas là
l'écran marche après marche même plutôt
bien pour voir qu'il est mouillé non
mais ça va pas mal donc c'est eux qui me
chagrine mois cette petite icône en os
qu'il a pris la flotte ici est ce qu un
petit défaut c'est pas impossible qu'il
ait pris l'eau au niveau de la prise
jack je pense que l'étanchéité au niveau
du casque est passé j'ai donc recours à
la manière forte
ça c'est bizarre je sais pas si c'est
normal c'est passé il donne inquiété là
ça va plus du tout là franchement c'est
pas terrible du tout j'ai voulu
redémarrer parce que j'avais l'icône que
je vous ai montré casque alors qu'ils
absolument rien de brancher après qu'il
ait passé une demi heure dans l'eau
comme indiqué sur les spécifications
techniques puisqu'une certifié 68 jeux
le redémarre et depuis tout à l'heure il
m'affiche ça il est strictement
impossible de faire autre chose
strictement impossible de le bouter de
faire aucune manip
j'appuie tous les côtés il ya absolument
rien à faire là il ya 19h33 je vais le
poser deux côtés et puis on verra demain
matin si ça va mieux ou pas en tout cas
c'est relativement mal engagée
hier soir j'ai tourné le test de ma
vidéo du pop tels p8 j'avais donc ce bug
d'affichage
j'ai laissé sécher après j'avais un
écran blanc qui s'allument et
s'éteignent temps en temps je vais
relire ce matin ils ont une charge
complète et la regarder et j'essaye de
l'allumer il se passe absolument rien le
téléphone est complètement nord voilà je
vous déconseille fortement d'acheter ce
téléphone le pop tels p8 si vous voulez
acheter mais vous êtes sûr qu'il
rencontrera jamais d'eau pourquoi pas et
pourquoi pas mais bon même s'il coûte
100 euros voir un petit peu moins la
qualité de l'écran est pas terrible
et dans cette gamme de tarifs je
conseille franchement d'aller vers des
marques comme ricco qui propose des
produits qui sont vraiment au dessus
malgré tout ce smartphone là je pourrais
bien faire quelque chose je peux donc
utilisé pour faire du basket du coup
désolé cocktail mais je pense que
fondamentalement on travaillera plus
jamais ensemble parce que je me dois
d'être loyal vis-à-vis de ma communauté
dans la mesure où vous regardez mes
vidéos c'est vous me faites confiance
fait confiance à mon avis à mon jugement
je vais certainement pas vous induire en
erreur sur un smartphone donc bon donc
je vous le dis carrément celui là en
tout cas faut l'oublier bon à coup sûr
ce smartphone salle fera pas mais par
contre il ya plein d'autres smartphones
hyper intéressant je vous invite donc à
aller visionner ma playlist pour vous
aider à choisir à découvrir les derniers
modèles et savoir quel smartphone est
fait pour vous et si vous voulez un
smartphone robuste ou chercher les tons
tchité la solidité un vrai smartphone
increvable et passe partout et bien je
vous invite à aller voir du côté de chez
cros col du côté de chez caterpillar
j'ai déjà fait plusieurs vidéos et
d'ailleurs à ce sujet je vais tester ce
smartphone le s 61 de caterpillar d'ici
quelques jours dont je vous invite bien
évidemment à rester connectés puis pour
tout choix de vos smartphones allez voir
les pistes
à bientôt ciao